can never drink Pepsi not this the
number one [__] thing
that that can just for half a second
ruin my concert or [__] Sports
experiences when I go into an arena and
I find that that Pepsi has the contract
what is that why are you guys like that
Pepsi is fine
I like Coke better but when the waiter
goes is Pepsi okay I'm like yeah you got
these people going
why I don't I never understood the hate
for Pepsi like that it's like watching
somebody [__] [__] up a steak
I it's still it's still gonna it's still
a stake so it can only taste so bad but
it could have been unbelievable it could
have been Paul it could have been
unbelievable but instead we got Pepsi